okay uh we have a duly knows work
session at 10 A.M we do not need a
quorum to open a work session uh so I'm
going to go ahead and fire it up because
it is 10 a.m we'll do a quick pledge uh
we may recess the work session but uh we
at least started on time so
uh the clerk you want to lead us up
Madam Clerk
okay
um so we've got three bills that we're
gonna deal with today we're obviously
not gonna vote on them right now
um I have for the committee I have
distributed an amendment to SB 170.
um
it should be it should be on your desk
uh I know I want I give it to everybody
but myself hold on
because
all right there we go
all right again to everybody but myself
um
so um listening to the committee's
discussion
um or rather hearings from SB 170 I
reinstated the
um crossed outlines and added a
provision afterwards that says provided
that after the after school and Hall
provided that the after school and
holiday increase in capacity is
permitted by the state fire code and in
compliance with any local ordinances so
I'm hoping that my goal there and we'll
discuss it when we
um
we will discuss that when we actually
take up the amendment but my goal there
is that will satisfy all parties
involved leave the
um after school increase in place for
where it currently exists or is
allowable but also recognizes that State
Fire code and stuff like that you have
to follow that so that's my goal there
um
McWilliams came in but I didn't see her
I believe she had an amendment or she
was drafting in a minute to
will gather her when he comes back
um on SB 221 obviously when we get to
Executive we'll actually vote on that my
hope is that a member will make a motion
to retain that bill
um I don't believe we are going to do
anything with it today but I think it
would be wise to hold on to it in case
we find something later in the year that
we want to grab we do have a vehicle not
that we're allowed to have placeholder
legislation wink wink nudge nudge but we
can have placeholder legislation if you
actually read our rules so
there she is
are you you're Distributing your
amendment to SB 94 I assume excellent
thank you
okay
and ribs and McWilliams can you give one
to our friends at DHHS
okay
um so we have these distributed
amendments we have my stated purpose on
sv221
um does any other member have anything
they'd like to say while we're in a work
session before we begin executive
sessions at 10 15.
does any member of the public we are in
a work session we're allowed to hear
from the public as a member of the
public wish to look at the relative
amendments that have been distributed in
opine
all right if that's the case I'm going
to recess our work session until uh 10
14. I'll reconvene it at 10 15
immediately close it
um in case we want to continue our work
session for whatever reason but I'll see
you guys at 10 14. so in 10 minutes
it to you remember
all right it's uh we're one minute
passed
um so I'm going to reopen our work
session and immediately end it
um now I will open up our executive
session we will take up SB 94 uh is
there a motion on SB 94
. I get to we have we need an ought to
pass motion first before we can move to
amend it so is there an emotion is there
an off to pass motion for all right
there's an ought to pass motion by
representative McWilliams is there a
second for there's a second by SB 94
um is there an amendment offered for SB
offer
Amendment 2023 1810h
all right representative McWilliams
offers a house Amendment 2023 1810h to
SB 94 is there a second
we'll take uh we'll take a second from
actually representative boss into the
clerk makes the life a little easier
um we are now in discussion on the
amendment is there a discussion on the
amendment Presby Williams like to speak
to your motion I would please and thank
you chair
um so during uh the hearing on SB 94 we
had a bit of a discussion about what may
happen if uh the age of a child with
special education or disabilities is
changed in the future and the fact that
restricting to a certain age might
actually lock us into needing to do an
amendment as a committee or even as the
entire House and Senate so rather than
locking it in the intention of this
amendment is to Simply refer to the
definitions under RSA 186 C2 regarding
receiving special education and related
Services by the child's School District
so we're putting this over to education
and if they decide to raise the age of
services in the future this will move in
lockstep with it so that's the end
attention of this amendment is just to
not lock children who fall under that
bucket into a certain age restriction
excellent Is there further discussion on
the amendment
um does anyone have any objection to
from DHHS commenting on the amendment we
are an executive session so it would be
without objection without objection it's
fine
thank you chair and representative of
the committee I'm Melissa Clement um
Chief the child care licensing unit and
I am definitely in favor of the
amendment but I just realized one thing
in reading it if we limit it to
um to a child with a disability as
defined under RSA 186 C2 that is a New
Hampshire Amendment and it may cause
issues for our out-of-state students who
are wouldn't fall under that definition
because they're coming from another
state so they're not
under that definition because then it's
not just New Hampshire students that
would be in these residential programs
we also have students from Massachusetts
from other states who are coming into
our residential programs they're being
placed there by an educational placement
but it's not under that statute it would
be under the statutes in their states so
I I like the idea behind this and not
trying to limit it to an age but I'm
also worried about how we might be able
to address the needs of those that are
coming from other states and making sure
we're not
we're allowing them to have that
Residential Care as well and remain in
care and I'm sorry this as I was reading
it that just came to me it wasn't we
have options
um
this is a general concern for the
committee do we want to proceed Fourth
Amendment do we want to
um recess the bill what do you what's
kind of the general disposition of the
committee for this
you don't you recognize representative
so
the schools from out of state all the
time
um and I would defer to however the
schools are treating those children who
are coming in from out of state even if
they're out of state children
um and so I do think that this
definition encompasses that I'm just
pulling it up to to read you know
exactly how it works here
um it does include every person under
the age 21 so you do have a very nice
coverall
to begin with
so I'm
I know this is you know
legislating in the middle of an exact
session it's hard because we just want
to vote yes or no on it
um
so I'm just pulling up the definitions
and it looks like it's pretty
encompassing here
um
child with a disability shall include a
child ages 18 to 21 who was identified
as a child with a disability and
received services in accordance with an
individual education program but who
left school prior to his or her
incarceration whoa okay or was
identified as a child with a disability
but did not have an IEP in his or her
last educational institution so
that could mean out of state I'm just
you know looking back
so I I think we probably would want to
hear from someone on the school side how
they handle this for people who come
from out of state because it seems like
this doesn't necessarily say you have to
have received services in New Hampshire
in order to qualify for the definition
of 1862 but we may not have that person
in this room
representative page just looking looking
at the definition
it does say evaluated by a school
district according to rules adopted by
the State Board of Education which I
assume would be
to New Hampshire so I and I and I want
to thank Ms Clement for bringing this up
representing a district where we have a
very large number of students remain in
our centers
um this is that is definitely a
consideration I'm glad you graced it had
not occurred to me
okay so we can um we have options here
I'll go back to my original question
which is how does the committee feel we
should handle this move forward we want
to recess the discussion of the
underlying bill
um to an executive session which I would
have to notice for next week most likely
to make our deadlines which is fine
I'll see you all next Wednesday
sorry representative page it's only it's
only a 18 minute drive for me it's only
an age
yes representative ball
I just had a question I'm sorry just for
a clarification
um it does say or special
identified by the child school district
and it doesn't specify if it's in-state
or out of state so doesn't that cover
all school districts and we do have this
vehicle called legislative intent which
is if it is put in our Clerk's note that
include out of state um
uh with first they'd have to find
somebody to sue then they'd have to find
somebody to go through the notes
um so we we do have this lovely vehicle
called legislative intent and if that is
our intent is to include students from
out of state
um and that is how this committee is
reading it and that is how it is
reflected in the official record taken
by our wonderful clerk
um then that um does actually become law
like that
um it just makes somebody having to put
it together in the future have a little
bit of a headache but we can always
adjust that later
so is that the is that the disposition
of this committee is that we believe
this encompasses out of state yes
representative Paul
School District
would that make a difference in
understanding that it's both in and out
of state if we say the child's home
school district or
that may not be relevant
my I guess my uh my response to that was
we if we amend the amendment um we can
then just do it we don't have to like
bend it at that point we can actually
just
explicitly say what we want we don't
have to be clever if we've amended the
amendment yes representative Neil
um the RSA wrong or incorrectly but when
I'm reading you know the rules I was
adopted by the State Board of Education
it's State Board of Education not
capitalized so it
is okay so we can't use that to just say
that that would encompass
Massachusetts New Hampshire Maine
yeah I mean they would have to the
person the people interpreting the
legislation that we pass would have to
first they're going to the first thing
they're going to do is they're going to
read it literally right so if the
literal reading of it means only New
Hampshire students then we have a
problem if it's Up For Debate
then they will go to legislative intent
which we get to dictate via the record
um and then they go to the courts
yes representative this may be the
lawyer in me but you know playing with
the words here I mean so we're saying as
the amendment's written up to the age of
a child with a disability is defined in
RSA 186 C2 and their receiving special
education from their school district but
whether whether this definition we have
here under RSA 186 C2 is exactly the
same as what's in Massachusetts Maine
Vermont or any of these other states to
me may not be relevant as long as the
child is meeting this definition
so wouldn't it still apply and cover
that child it seems like it certainly
could to me
uh if you catch my drift it seems like
it certainly could to me
maybe when we meet next year we'll fix
that
so so they really know what we mean is
everybody on board with that
all right is there any further
discussion on the amendment thank you
and our legislative incentive is very
clear it means all students
irregardless our legislative attendance
is very clear
um that's why I will be voting for the
Amendments because it includes all
students there we go
is there any further discussion on the
amendment
hearing none the clerk will call the
wall
sorry yes representative O'Neill
representative page yes and the chair
chair votes yes
nine yays zero knees and with that uh
Amendment 2023 1810h is adopted to SB
94. we are now on discussion on the
underlying Bill uh the motion is now
ought to pass as amended is there
discussion on the bill as amended
yes uh Vice chairman
I'd like to move thank you I would like
to move otpa on uh House Bill 94. okay I
believe there's I'll second it we're on
otpa for the underlying bill there's a
discussion on the bill as admitted
okay hearing none the clerk will call
the roll
representative
I just thinking make sure when you uh
vote to turn your mics on as somebody
who watches these at home because that's
my life uh I can't hear you can't hear
how you vote if you don't turn my clock
I will repeat my yay vote thank you uh
representative ball
representative Nelson yes
representative Waller yes
representative Christian votes yes
representative McWilliams yes
representative O'Neill yes
representative page yes and the chair
terrible chess
and with that uh SB
uh 94 will be reported out of committee
as ought to pass as amended um
representative McWilliams will you do
the committee report please thank you
for the record yes
um uh with that I'm closing the
executive session on SB 94 I'm opening
the executive session on SB uh 170 which
is titled here it is um here we go uh
relative to small group child day care
centers uh would somebody like to make a
motion for SB 170.
somebody like to make another pass uh
representative page means ought to pass
is there a second
uh reperative decent money seconds uh
with that I will recognize myself
and I would like to introduce Amendment
um 2023-1899h
um and I would love it if somebody would
second me second thank you
representative for the the second we are
now on discussion on the amendment uh I
will again recognize myself to speak to
my own Amendment
Gotta Love parliamentary procedure
um so after listening to the
um
the concerns about the issues
surrounding the fire code and the
confusion I reintroduced the I unstruck
the lines
um that reduced the before and after
school chair care and holiday care but I
included in the RSA what I would call
clarifying language so that if there to
reduce the confusion
um so the language is very simple it
unstrikes the lines and incurts the
Clause afterwards provided that after
school and holiday provided that the
after school and holiday increase in
capacity is permitted by the state fire
code and in compliance with any local
ordinances
um so I did that to relieve the
confusion I was going I want to pass the
underlying Bill I'm not discussing the
online bill right now but my I was going
to have issues voting for it if it could
be in any which way interpreted as
potentially constraining new supply of
child care in the state of New Hampshire
so um I tried to strike that middle
ground of keep the Bill if it actually
changes nothing in terms of
functionality that is my goal
um but it I I think it would my hope is
that it assuages the concerns from the
public about confusion for new centers
um but also what I believe are my
concerns which are about limiting
potential increasing capacity which is
what I view as the current crisis of
health of child care in the state of New
Hampshire so that's my opening solve on
the amendment I'm sure others would like
to speak to it
or maybe they wouldn't okay
um
well I would like to hear from the um
licensing and from the fire code
people about how this amendment they're
they're showing you what they want
I would like to hear how I know you like
the amendment I like I guess I'd like
I'd like to hear how in everyday life
how does this affect what um what
providers are going to be able to how
many children writers can care for okay
without objection because once again we
are an executive so without exactly
without objection
thank you representative I'm so if I'm
understanding your question correctly
you want to know how this is going to
impact day-to-day Life by able to
specifying clearly in the statute which
we can also communicate to Providers
we're able to show that we this is what
the statute will require but you also
have to be in compliance with whatever
your local ordinances require and also
whatever the State Fire Marshal requires
for the numbers that you wish to care
for right now without have with with the
bare bones amen sorry definition just
saying that you could have nine children
as a family child care or you could have
17 children with because because of the
additional school age they think that
they're able to do that and then they're
finding along the way that their local
codes won't require it or the State Fire
Marshal codes won't require it and it
just creates a lot of angst for them
because they were under the impression I
can have 17 children and thinking that
they could apply for that but then
finding out there are other restrictions
along the way that's preventing them
from doing doing so so it'll help and
it'll also help with the local
um both like planning boards and Zoning
committees because they tend to adopt
our definitions they will see that
clearly stated there so they will have
to look at them what their local
ordinances are to see if they have any
impediments or what restrictions they
have
um so uh you wrote to us that there were
probably around 40 providers right now
who have the license that allows them to
go up to 17 I guess how will that affect
how will this affect that those 40. it
actually shouldn't affect them at all
now because it'll they'll they will
remain they will remain they won't need
the grandfather clause no yeah we won't
have to we won't have to change any of
the license types everything will remain
as is and this will clarify the
confusion moving forward okay and new
providers that came in who meet
the um
codes are going to be able to go up to
17. if their local ordinances allow for
that and if their state fire code allows
for if they've been approved for that
number through this local
um fire inspection yes okay let's have
one more question of course so one of
the
um
Solutions you put forward originally
when we saw this bill was that people
who had licenses for up to six family
child care providers would now be called
group family child care
we don't need to do that now we won't
need to do that great thank you
representative Simone
thank you I'd like to move the question
if
committees
amenable
um we we can do that our rules are are
we operate our Masons and moving to
questions kind of a weird one in our
roles um so we'll we'll finish um we'll
let all the members who want to speak
speak
um but then yes because it's uh I don't
want to get by if this was Robert's
Rules of Order you could absolutely move
to previous question and we would do
that right away
full list of residential zoning
ordinances for family child care and a
lot of them have it seems much uh
stricter restrictions on the number of
children that can be cared for
um does adding in
in compliance with any local ordinance
mean that
or make any change to how they have to
do that does it restrict the number of
children it's certainly not because they
should be already in compliance with
local ordinances
um so it's clarifying language right so
it's it's clarifying So in theory they
if they already have the ability to do
this which they clearly do from our
excellent document from our community
researcher
um they already have to abide by
themselves it doesn't that that part of
it doesn't change anything
I would never bring forward something
that would restrict
child care I would hope you I would hope
you I hope you hope you know me better
than that
um further discussion on the amendment
uh hearing none uh I will um the clerk
will call the roll
should we
do yes we are we have the motion the
amendment has been moved to adopt you I
believe you seconded it so we're all set
we are
we have to pass the movement first
we haven't voted on the amendment I I
assume I feel good about it but we have
to do the vote first
I forgot where we were I'm old
thanks for giving me a little extra time
to get my paperwork uh representative
DeSimone yes
representative ball yes
representative Nelson yes
representative Waller yes
representative Christian votes yes uh
representative McWilliams yes
representative O'Neill yes
representative page yeah and the clerk
or a chair sorry uh chair votes yes um
the chair Zone Amendment
um
all right nine to zero nine zero with
that um Amendment 2023 19 1899 H is
added to SB 170. uh we are now on the
underlying bill as amended uh we have to
do a new motion as our motion to
octopass has amended uh that so moved so
moved is there a second representative
Nelson seconds the motion of ought to
pass this amendment we are now in
discussion of the underlying bill as
amended
um is there discussion on SB 170 as
hearing none the clerk will call the
roll
representative
yes
uh representative ball yes
representative Nelson yes representative
on there yes
representative Christian votes yes
representative McWilliams
yes
representative O'Neill yes
representative page yes
yes and the chair uh chair votes yes
um with that uh SB 170 will be reported
out of committee is off to pass as
amended um I will take care of the
committee report
um
and we are now I'm now going to close
the executive session on SB 170 I'm
going to open the executive session on
SB 221
um is there a motion on SB 221 yes
representative D Simone thank you Mr
chair I would like to make a motion to
retain uh send a bill to 21.
um oh I forgot to read the title
establishing a study committee to
examine daycare access and affordability
is there a second on the motion to
retain sb221 representative McWilliams
second is there a discussion on the
motion to retain sp221 hearing none the
clerk will call the roll
all right uh representative DeSimone yes
representative ball yes
representative Nelson yes
representative walner yes
representative Christian votes yes
representative McWilliams yes
representative O'Neill yes
representative page yes and the chair
votes yes and with that SB 221 is
retained I will be closing the uh
actually I'm going to pause this because
I can't close just yet because we're
still meeting um I will uh I'll send
something around to the committee over
our next two meetings about what we're
going to talk about
um it's going to be things relative to
SB 221 which we've just retained
um as well as the grant States for
Quality Access program
um and some other ideas that I got
kicked around my head so be on the
lookout for that um and with that I will
close our executive session and I will
see you all tomorrow on the house floor
thank you